and the very first thing that you do
every single morning is slam that snooze
button and tell yourself in the process
that it's okay not to hit your goal
maybe you have a habit that you're
trying to change too we can go on this
journey together the secret to getting
the head is doing your job
well what's that believe nation it's
Evan my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have an
amazing gift inside you that I want to
see explode out onto the world so to
help you on your journey today I'm gonna
talk about the seven toxic habits that
you want to avoid in life enjoy so I
strongly believe that we are we
consistently do there's no such thing as
somebody who's just born lazy and you
know that has no ambitions and doesn't
want to make the world a better place I
think you're just a product of your
environment and your habits your habits
for the most part may have some that
serve you but a lot of them suck and a
lot of your friends probably doing a lot
of these things too and if you look at
how you are consistently spending your
time that's what you'll consistently get
and so mapping your actions your habits
your daily schedule to your ambition to
what you want to do to the goals do they
match this work that you're doing here
will it allow you to create the world
that you want to create over here and
for too many people it doesn't you want
to be here but you're not doing what you
need to be doing here there's too many
toxic habits here so today I'm gonna
share with you the seven toxic habits
that you need to immediately eliminate
from your life whoa
Nina's excited
[Music]
toxic habit number one is snoozing most
people what they do first thing every
day is wake up and hit the snooze button
and there's a whole bunch of reasons why
that's not actually very healthy for you
and you can go and look at the science
behind sleep research and snoozing and
what it does to you but more important
for me is think about what you have done
the night before you say I'm gonna wake
up at 7 o'clock the next day or I'm
gonna wake up at 8 o'clock the next day
you set this goal for yourself right
like this is what I'm gonna do tomorrow
morning and then the very first thing
that you do every single morning is slam
that snooze button and tell yourself in
the process that it's okay not to hit
your goal that it's okay that I set a
goal for myself and I don't follow
through and so that's how you start your
day every morning how do you think
you're gonna go off and have no an
amazing day you have triggered yourself
every single morning to say I'm the kind
of person who sets goals and doesn't
follow through that's what you've
telling yourself every single morning
and so if you expect to then go off and
have an amazing day to set other goals
and actually reach them you're fooling
yourself I highly recommend if you need
that extra sleep you need that extra
seven minutes or 14 minutes or 30
minutes or how many times you're
smashing the snooze button then just set
the alarm for seven or fourteen or
thirty minutes later and when it goes
off you get up and now you're starting
to rewire a new identity
now you're telling yourself I set a goal
and I do it even though it's hard even
though I'm tired even though I had a
rough night last night
even though whatever it is you do as
soon as you set a goal for yourself and
this applies not a much more than
snoozing as soon as you set a goal for
yourself to say I'm gonna do this then
every time that you don't do that goal
you're creating that identity for
yourself that it's okay that I'm the
kind of person who does not follow
through my goals and every time you set
a goal and you do follow through then
that's a new identity that you're
creating for yourself that I'm the kind
of person who sets goals and follows
through these micro battles these micro
goals that you're setting for yourself
every single day shape your identity and
to have success as an entrepreneur you
need to be the kind of person who sets
goals and follows through and so I wanna
be very careful around any kind of goal
that you set for yourself any kind of
any kind of goal that you're saying I'm
gonna I'm gonna get this done because
once you set that goal you have to go
out and do it and most importantly tie
it to your snoozing stop hitting the
snooze button every single morning go
out and actually wake up and achieve the
first goal that you set for yourself
every single morning toxic combat number
two is waking up like an accident
most people wake up like an accident
most people have no morning routine most
people wake up they've already hit the
snooze button a couple times now they're
running late forever they have to get to
they just rush out of the house you know
get a quick cup of coffee maybe a quick
breakfast and the leaf and you wake up
being rushed live into somebody else's
agenda instead of owning the day and
again if you start your morning rushed
living to somebody else's agenda it can
be really really really hard to get back
on track to living the day that you want
to live and so the best way to do it is
to start first thing in the morning so
you want to reverse engineer it and that
if you know you need to be at work by a
certain time or meet so many by a
certain time than to do that you have to
backup X number of hours that's the time
you have to wake up and even before that
to wake up at this time you have to go
to bed the night before at that time
right planning it all out and then
figure out what does ideal morning
routine look like for you what is the
thing that makes you feel bold and
confident and alive and unstoppable
because you've all had those moments
right you have felt that moment of
boldness and say this is awesome I can
do anything it just happened so randomly
you don't build that into your morning
routine it's something that you you
happen to come across a YouTube video
that inspires you you happen to have a
conversation or listen to a podcast or
read a book that inspires you and then
for that day you're on fire but then you
fall back down to zero the next morning
if you can reverse engineer the thing
that gets you feeling super bold then
figure out how to put that into your
morning routine every single day it's
why I started the N special series it's
supposed to be a shot of espresso every
single morning it's wisdom it's fire
it's motivation it's inspiration it's a
quick video that while you're eating
breakfast are getting ready you can
watch and hopefully fill your head with
some inspiration from me I don't wake up
every morning like gosh this is amazing
I love today right I wish
I read a page from my book you know I I
don't have it on me here we're on
vacation right now I'm in my cruise
cabin I I read a page from my book
and on that pages is two great ideas
from amazing thought leaders and that
gets me inspired ready to start my
morning whatever the thing is for you
though maybe it's running maybe it's
exercise maybe it's yoga maybe it's
meditation maybe it's having a cold
shower maybe it's watching an
interesting video maybe it's reading the
book maybe it's having a phone
conversation ever the thing is no
judgment whatever the thing is that gets
you feeling bold and unstoppable because
you know what that thing is because you
felt those moments in the past then find
a way the fact that that into your
morning routine so that every day you
are doing that if you stopped waking up
like an accident
living somebody else's dream rushing
somewhere on somebody else's timetable
if you stop doing that to control the
day and put that boldness into your
morning routine your life would be
unrecognizable a year from today if you
did that consistently I promise you so
stop waking up like an accident
[Music]
the number three toxic habit to avoid is
blaming and complaining and I'll tie
into that too hanging around people who
blame and complain when you blame and
complain it does two things one it makes
you feel good because it's somebody
else's fault right of course add that
look at the snow the weather my boss the
education system my family whatever it
feels so great to let the stress off our
shoulders and blame and complain it's
always somebody else's fault we don't
have to take responsibility for it it
feels amazing the second part of it
though is it makes you stay where you
are if all you're doing is spotting the
negativity and blaming somebody else and
you'll never grow you never improve it
look at the most successful
entrepreneurs and see how they started
their companies whoever it is that you
look up to see how they got started
chances are was because of a crisis
there was a big problem and instead of
saying this sucks I can't believe that
this thing is happening they said this
is where entrepreneurs flip it we go
this is an opportunity this is my chance
this is my shot this is the way that I
can win finally here we go
u-turn crisis into an opportunity but as
long as you're living in the blame in
the complaining world it's never gonna
you will never grow the genius ideas
that you have you'll just sit around and
watch other people make tons of money
off of them and then you'll blame a
complaint against a that was my idea
well no it wasn't because you didn't
take action on it they did that's the
difference
it could be somebody who is not as smart
as you not as much as a genius as you
not as talented as you and they will win
because they did something positive
about instead of just thinking about it
and then complaining about all the
resources that you don't have the second
part of all this is hanging around
people who blame and complain you are a
product of your environment the people
who you hang around with you they're
gonna rub off on you you come up to
somebody in this it's like it's like
scurvy you know it's like a infectious
disease it's gonna it's gonna rub off on
you you're gonna get it and so I would
spend a good chunk of time just trying
to think about who I'm spending my time
with and what kind of resources I'm
consuming and does it allow me to build
positivity does it allow me to get
pushed towards my goal it's why I
created the top ten series in the meant
to me series for me personally because
not that I had so many scurvy toxic
people around me but more I wanted
people to pull me in the right direction
to push me into doing much bigger things
and so by the same token if you're
around all these negative complaining
complaining people who are in your
personal life that's what you're gonna
be you're the average of the five
closest people you're gonna become like
that but if you start hanging around
with people who've done a lot more and
who are positive and who are ambitious
and who are driving forward that's gonna
rub off on you too and the top ten
series and the mentor me series that's
my exact goal it's not even so much the
individual tactics that you can take
it's not that Bill Gates did
partnerships and so you can do
partnerships it's not as much the
specific tactics although those are
helpful it's more just the mindset if
you are hanging around these successful
people and seeing the boldness and
things that they're chasing it will rub
off on to you you will want to go off
and be bolder and think differently and
start chasing your goals because these
are now the people in your environment
and so I mean ideally it's it's people
face-to-face ideally you know you're and
you're in a circle and all your friends
are lifting you up you always want to be
the weakest chain in the fence but
that's not always possible and when it's
not don't don't just give up look at
aspirational Mentors
videos books podcasts whatever the thing
is again that gets you feeling bold
pushing forward that's what you want to
go after as a side note if you want to
take this seriously I would challenge
you to find the five closest people to
you and this something that I did and
ask him to call you out every time
you're complaining and blaming if they
ever hear a complaint or something or
you're blaming somebody else that they
call you out on it and and it's a fun
little game for them it's fun it's fun
to watch you have to eat it that
practice of what are you gonna say like
you know what you're right
I didn't complain them again a lot of
this is subconscious a lot of this
you're just doing naturally you're
falling into your old habits and
patterns again and so you may be able to
catch it yourself but having people
around you say hey hey hey hey you you
you're complaining again stop it you can
really help you break that habit toxic
habit number four is not giving your all
there was this great clip that we did
from Mitt Romney's top ten rules and
it's the only clip that really sunk in
with me and when he was saying the
secret to getting ahead is doing your
current job well hardwork ennobling work
dive into your profession with passion
and hearts go beyond what's expected or
required and in doing so by the way you
will learn the secret to advancement and
that is doing your present job well
right the secret to getting ahead is
doing your job well
my ultimate goal with everything I'm
doing is to it's constantly living in
the moment to constantly feel like
whatever I'm doing this is valuable and
I'm gonna make the best of it whether
that's in business whether that's in
personal life whether that whether I'm
sleeping like when I'm sleeping I want
to be sleeping I want to be in the zone
on sleeping and when I'm spending time
with Nina I want to be in the zone
spending time with Nina and I think too
often were one distracted and we're
thinking about the thing that's next
instead of the thing that we're doing
right now and to if it's something that
that we don't have a lot of interest in
or you know we don't see the big
connection to or it's not exactly what
want to be doing for a lot of people
they they stop or they just do the bare
minimum doing the bare minimum
never be acceptable as much as possible
because when you do great work you never
know how it's gonna come back to you you
never know where it's gonna be
recognized but I guarantee you if you
just spend your entire life doing the
bare minimum which most people do they
do just enough work not to get fired
right if that's how you spend your life
then you're never gonna win you'll
constantly be where you are and have
like maybe tiny promotions over the
years but if you took the philosophy and
mind set up whatever I do this is this
is what I will tell myself and and Nina
Aidan that probably heard this a lot of
times but it's like I'm Evan Carmichael
and when I attack something it's gonna
be awesome
whatever that thing is if it's planning
for this trip it's gonna be the best
plan that I can possibly create and I'm
gonna put my all into making that
amazing if it's planning for Nina's
birthday I'm gonna do my best to make it
a fantastic birthday for her if I'm
making videos for you guys I'm here
thinking about how do I make the best
videos for you guys and not everything
gets recognized immediately and some of
it may never get recognized at all but
if you put your all into every moment as
much as possible as an entrepreneur as a
husband wife as a as a as a parent if
you put your all into every moment I
guarantee you some of those are gonna
pay off and you're gonna get ahead and
start winning toxic habit number five is
looking for nose instead of yeses where
to start on this one this is so powerful
because when something new is introduced
there's always gonna be changed you're
always gonna have to be coming up with
some new ideas and just even reacting to
the market there's always gonna be
newness right YouTube's algorithms gonna
change a new social media network is
gonna come out your best client is gonna
leave you your best employees are gonna
go off and start their own companies
like change is gonna happen it's just
gonna happen and when a new opportunity
comes up what a lot of people do is they
look for the no instead of the S they
look for reasons why it's not gonna work
out instead of why it will work out so
example maybe you should start a YouTube
channel you know YouTube kind of a
popular place to be kind of a
opportunity to have a lot of impact have
a lot of people watch your videos which
can lead to reputation brand awareness
sailes lots of different stuff most
people's approach to YouTube would be
this ok fine
let's give it a shot this whole YouTube
thing I'm not buying it but let's just
try it ok they make three videos it
doesn't take off and they quit they're
looking for all the reasons why it's not
gonna work out they're looking for all
the knows possible and then they give up
we're what you want to do is look for
the guess you want to be the one person
who finds the one reason why it will
work out if you just switch that mindset
where a new opportunity came to you a
new challenge a new way of doing
business a new way of reaching out and
you consistently look for how is this
going to work instead of spending so
much time in the Y this is not gonna
work when you can move to that bucket
how can I make this work if you're
asking that question you start finding
ways to make a link and that's when you
start to win because at the beginning of
anything you don't have a perfect plan
especially in a new emerging market
right if you're launching on YouTube you
don't have a perfect plan you don't know
what you're doing you can create an
approximate plan that's okay if you're
launching new product or service you
don't have a perfect plan so there's
gonna be holes and you can either be the
person who just looks for all the holes
in the planning and that's why it's not
gonna work out or looks for the one
thing that if it stands on this then it
doesn't matter both of these holes will
fill them and we're gonna win who are
you you got to make a choice make it
powerfully stop looking for nose start
looking for yeses
[Music]
the number-6 toxic habit to avoid is
self-sabotage this happened so much as
people start to get a little bit of
success a little tiny little tiny taste
a little inkling of success people often
will start to self-sabotage they'll find
ways to get back to the comfort zone
they'll have that moment of boldness
right and start start rising up and
start hitting out the edge now I'm on
the scary spot I haven't been here
before this this is too crazy I can't do
this I've never done this before I
didn't go to school for this I don't
know what to do and then this sabotage
can go back down and I used to do this
around speaking I remember being invited
to go asked to speak at a bunch of
different events a lot of international
speaking and because it was three or
four or five months out I'd say yeah
sure no problem that's okay happy to
come out I'm excited for that but as we
got closer to the date I would secretly
hope that they would cancel the event
and I would find that a practical reason
to say I'm just too busy you know all of
these practical reasons but really I was
just afraid I was afraid I was afraid to
speak on international stage I was
afraid to speak to so many people's you
know this event might have camera crews
that they're gonna broadcast at
nationally I was afraid and so me
bumping up against that comfort zone of
what's what's easy creates that feeling
in your stomach right and so we always
try to come back to a safe place and we
do it by justifying all the reasons why
we can't go off and do that instead of
recognizing that this is just fear
talking and I need to get through it to
be able to ultimately reach my goal and
so this happens so often when people get
a small win or they're getting close to
a win they pull back they retreat you
want to avoid that and you want to try
to catch and that's the hardest part
that is the hardest part
catching it having a self-awareness to
catch it in the moment
you'll start by catching it after it
happened a week later a couple days
later a day later you'll catch you
saying I did it again you know what I
can't sit on that person are I wanted to
not to go through where I didn't give it
my all
because I was really just afraid of that
situation there was a situation I could
have made a bold move and I didn't and I
was just afraid not gonna let that
happen again
and eventually you'll get close and
closer to the point so it's like a week
later a couple days later they later a
couple hours later and then you'll get
to that scary point you'll get to that
point where you're about to do it again
it's coming up here is this opportunity
here's a scary situation chance for you
to prove yourself that you may fail you
may not work out and you're about to
retreat again you're about to go back to
the safe place and say no thank you or
go through something else or take a
different opportunity you're about to
retreat and you catch it what do you do
for me it's feeling the fear and doing
it anyway
it's fast-forwarding projecting 50 years
of regret of saying no or turning down
that opportunity because I was afraid
and I make the future for you're so big
that overcomes my present fear of taking
that action I want to take but it starts
with the self-awareness because most of
the self-sabotage happens subconsciously
you just do it on automatic and so if
you can catch any of it then when you
get to that moment you have to make a
powerful decision that I will not
sabotage this opportunity I'm gonna
write it I may fail but I'd rather fail
than not know and toxic habit number
seven is trying to do everything
yourself a lot of times in these growth
situations we're trying to learn new
habits we're trying to kind of stretch
that comfort zone again we don't often
share it with other people who try to do
it all ourselves and when there's zero
accountability it's really hard to be
accountable just to yourself it's doable
all of these things are doable but why
make it so difficult when you are
accountable to somebody else you're much
more likely to follow through I look at
my my gym track record right I go to the
gym two times a week and I go because
I'm a personal trainer I hired a
personal trainers name is Shawn's and
Nina and I go twice a week and we train
with him and if Sean is not around if
Sean is on vacation or you know for
whatever reason can't make it our
consistent seed drops a little bit and
if Sean and Nina weren't around my
consistency would would fall off even
more and so if there's something that
you're working on something that you
want to try to get better at it really
really helps to bring other people into
the loop to be vulnerable to say hey
here's something that I'm working on
here's something I'm trying to improve
about myself here's a habit that I think
is toxic that
trying to change I could really use your
support maybe you have a habit that
you're trying to change too we can go on
this journey together we're just that
very active knowing that you have to
report in to somebody you know I look at
our training with Sean one of the things
we have to do is track our calories and
track our protein intake and the fact
that I know that I have to report the
Shawn the next morning means I stick to
my goal even though it is very
self-serving right the goal is for me
the goal is for me to get to certain
weight categories and all that stuff but
knowing that I have to report in makes
sure that I stick to it because I don't
want to tell Shawn Shawn I went over but
400 calories because I eat that ice
cream you know every now and then maybe
but on a consistent basis it allows me
to follow through and so I would very
highly recommend you talk to a friend
you get an accountability buddy whatever
the goal is whatever I have a change
you're trying to make don't just do it
yourself you're much less likely to
follow through find somebody to be your
partner you each pick a goal you need to
check in on a daily basis to see how
you're doing support each other you're
much more likely to actually make that
happen
change stick so thank you guys so much
for watching those are my seven toxic
habits that I think you should avoid I
would love to know which one resonated
the most with you which one are you
having the hardest time dealing with is
there an 8 9 10 that you want to add to
the list leave it down the comments
below thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that that people
passion and not one drop of my
self-worth depends on your that's
supposed to mean I don't ever give up
I'd have to be
dead or completely incapacitated hey
believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten rows to
success I have a very special secret
video for you these are the individual
clips that I have personally learned the
most from and applied to my life and my
business check the link in description
for details